there's a heatwave in the uk and a
warning of a danger to our health with
temperatures creeping towards 40 degrees
celsius so let's update you on that
first should we some parts of the uk
have already seen record temperatures
with north elton west london recording
32 degrees yesterday and last weekend
parts of the uk were hotter than hawaii
and also los angeles the met office has
issued a rare amber extreme heat warning
meaning there's a risk of serious
illness or even a danger to life and if
computer modelling is to be believed the
uk could see temperatures of up to 40
degrees for the first time unlikely but
the met office says we could be seeing
new record temperatures later this week
even train tracks caught fire yesterday
after a spark ignited dry wooden beams
the blades in battersea says saw
services between victoria and brixton
suspended elsewhere network rail is
warning trains may have to run slower
due to high track temperatures
temperatures hit
32 degrees in west london yesterday
which had people flocking to lido's and
heading for the coastal beaches let's go
to north west london maddie standing by
for us
thankfully at a cool golf course but
it's going to heat up later on isn't it
maddie good morning
good morning kate yes it is i mean these
temperatures are more suited to the
caribbean really than the uk and it is
affecting businesses people services are
struggling with these temperatures there
are reports even in the telegraph that
yesterday cobra met to actually discuss
the uk's first uk health emergency and
the disruption that would bring to
schools and transport as well as health
services but it is already having an
impact and here at the golf course it is
quite a challenge uh trying to keep the
courses green and playable but i am
joined by jim who has 30 50 sorry 50
years experience doing this tell me
how you're how you're trying to cope
with the heat here well basically we try
and get the staff in earlier finish a
bit earlier hand watering dry patches
the problem with the grains is they're
100 years young to one constructed
properly and consistent soils so we do
but generally we try and just put enough
water on keep the grass alive because we
don't want to over water
we can't play winter time so it's
getting a balance right
and as i say just hand water and even
though we've got a new navigation system
that works brilliantly
you have to get someone out to put on
these dry areas
of course and it's not just the the
staff like you say it's also the players
who will have to try and keep cool in
the heat because these temperatures are
only going to get hotter